نزل السائحون الأجانب
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
إلى دبي للاستمتاع بمشاهدة
بحر الشمس والرمال
في الشهر الماضي ، حيث كان العديد من السياح أكثر
ثراءً في كرة القدم أو كرة القدم للكثيرين في
جميع أنحاء العالم
وفقًا لمجلس دبي الرياضي ، حيث
تم تعيين ما يقرب من مليون زائر إضافي على  مدينة
خلال مونديال 2022 التي تقام
في دول الخليج في قطر ، لذا فإن
التأثير المتتالي لمونديال قطر
في دبي له علاقة بالتقارب
أولاً وقبل كل شيء تتأثر المنطقة
بشدة بكأس العالم ، فقد
أظهر أن هناك  هي قدرة
هائلة وحماس هائل وجنون رياضي
في المنطقة ، وبما أن المشجعين
حريصون على تجربة مباريات كرة القدم ، فإن
شركات الطيران تستجيب للدعوة إلى
زيادة أعداد الزوار خلال
كأس العالم ، فإن
توقعاتنا عبر المطار
للربع الأخير من هذا العام في DWC
هي شيء  مثل
494000 وسيسافر الغالبية العظمى من هؤلاء
من وإلى كأس العالم ،
وهناك الكثير من مواقف السيارات المجانية
وقمنا بترتيب ما يصل إلى 120 رحلة
ذهابًا وإيابًا كل يوم حتى
يتمكن المشجعون من المرور عبر المطار
بسرعة وسهولة ،
ولكن عندما لا يسافر المشجعون
لمشاهدة المباريات ، فإنهم يشاهدونها في
العديد من مناطق مشجعي كرة القدم
وينظمها رمزي ناكاد  واحدة من أكبر
المواقع
لدينا أكبر شاشة
تبلغ مساحتها 330 مترًا مربعًا ، ولدينا صوت غامر رباعي الأبعاد
يضعك تمامًا
في قلب كل الأحداث كما لو كنت
في منتصف
الملعب ، فالمدينة ليست غريبة.  لاستضافة
الزائرين لأحداث كبيرة العام الماضي ، كانت
موطنًا لمعرض إكسبو الدولي مع ملايين
الزوار الدوليين القادمين إلى
المدينة في عام 2021 ،
ما يجعل دبي جذابة لعشاق كرة
القدم هو أنها وجهة راسخة نسبيًا
تلبي
احتياجات معظم أسواق المصدر حيث
يأتي مشجعو كرة القدم
من الفرق التي تتنافس على أرض الملعب للحصول
على اللقب ، وقد فازت دبي خارج الملعب
وأصبحت موقعًا ليس فقط للباحثين عن الشمس
ولكن لعشاق الرياضة كما نحن  ll
[تصفيق]